[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78
nous sommes le lundi 23 octobre tout de
suite les titres de cette édition
elle a été l'une des principales
opposantes au pacs et au mariage pour
tous christine boutin se retire de la
vie politique française à 73 en libye
noise fondatrice du parti
chrétien-démocrate l'annoncé samedi lors
d'une conférence de presse à rambouillet
interview en début de journal lui en
cours met en place son périmètre urbain
une phase d'étude de 10 ans qui concerne
le quartier du village autour de la
mairie est la commune souhaite ainsi
mieux maîtriser son urbanisme et le
développement de son centre ville
composé d' éléments remarquables et
protégés
et puis en ligne de mire devenir la
meilleure boulangerie de france la
maison de pâte à pain en avoir contre
chartres 1 représente les yvelines
demain et dans une émission concours sur
la chaîne m6 derrière cette boulangerie
un couple antonia et richard hill de
verre qui sont nos invités
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres est
les vacances de la toussaint ou bien a
débuté et les forces de l'ordre et très
les forces de l'ordre étaient présentes
vendredi au moment des départs en
vacances une opération de sécurité
routière d'envergure a été menée sur
tout le territoire 18 points de contrôle
comme à rambouillet que vous voyez ici
en images 410 véhicules contrôlés pour
un total de 22 infractions relevées
particularité c'était une opération dite
concertée entre plusieurs services de
police
objectif affiché d'endiguer la mortalité
sur les routes
propos recueillis par michael et demi
d'euros le nombre de décès a légèrement
augmenté
on est passé de 18 pour la même période
du 1er janvier au 15 octobre à 23 cette
année on s'aperçoit que d'une manière
générale
au delà des facteurs habituels qui sont
la vitesse et l'alcool
on a un nouveau facteur qui apparaît
c'est le
manque de respect entre monte au mot
liste certains prenant une part de
risque ou ne respectant plus les règles
élémentaires du code de la route
fin de carrière après 40 ans passés dans
la politique christine boutin se retire
elle l'a confirmé samedi en conférence
de presse à rambouillet ancienne
candidate à la présidentielle de 2002
figure de la droite conservatrice
christine boutin avait fondé le parti
chrétien démocrate en 2009
souvenez-vous l'ex député des yvelines
avait eu des échanges virulents avec
lionel jospin à l'assemblée nationale en
plein à débat sur le pacs c'était en
1998 elle revient sur ses combats et
conviction au micro de tv 78 nicolas
d'ambri l'a interviewé christine boutin
vous avez 73 ans vous êtes président
d'honneur du parti chrétien-démocrate
vous avez participé à votre dernière
séance du conseil départemental des
yvelines
ce vendredi 20 octobre après avoir
occupé ce mandat depuis plus de 35 ans
alors pourquoi vous avez décidé de
démissionner tout d'abord je veux dire
est que la séance du conseil
départemental hier c'était très beau
c'était très très beau que je voulais
absolument rien mais j'ai été très très
touché par l'authenticité des réactions
de chacun de mes collègues je l'avais en
remercier jean mercier pierre bédier
pour cela alors pourquoi je démissionne
tout simplement parce que je tiens mise
en scène des engagements en 2015 quand
nous sommes présentés avec georges bizet
je m'étais engagé auprès des électeurs a
démissionné au milieu de mon mandat
compte tenu de mon âge parce que j'ai
beaucoup hésité à me représenter
compte tenu de cet âge avait 70 ans et
qu' il y avait un risque front national
très important surtout quand on est donc
après en avoir discuté du reste avec
pierre bédier g qui m'a encouragé à me
représenter
j'ai décidé de partir mais en ayant
cette obligation de quitter au milieu du
mandat
donc je tiens mes engagements comme j'ai
essayé de le faire tout au long de ses
40 années de vie politique qui s'achève
effectivement le 31 octobre prochain
alors vous avez commencé votre carrière
professionnelle dans la communication et
la presse et vous débutez votre carrière
politique dans les yvelines lors des
élections municipales de 1977 à
auffargis pourquoi vous êtes lancé en
politique en 77 quand nous sommes
arrivés enfin nous sommes arrivés dans
les yvelines avec mon mari mes enfants
73 et en 77
il y avait les élections municipales et
moi j'avais dans le coeur depuis
toujours de servir de servir je sais ça
ce que j'avais envie et on peut servir
de mille manières né en étant élu local
parce que j'avais une tradition locale
dans le berry d'élu local dans ma
famille je suis allé voir le maire et je
vais proposer ma candidature est déjà en
le fait d'avoir une femme sur une liste
c'était bien mais vous me permettez de
saluer monsieur lévesque qui était le
maire de l'époque qui a été un
personnage déterminant dans ma carrière
politique puisque lui même à penser le
voyant à l'oeuvre à auffargis que je
pouvais devenir conseiller départemental
ce qui n'était absolument pas mon idée à
l'époque une fois que je suis devenu
conseiller municipal de farges ismer
d'auffargis naturellement j'ai plus vu
la réalité de ce territoire et je me
suis attaché
et comment ne pas s'attacher à ce sud
yvelines qui est un territoire
absolument magnifique
donc je me suis mise au service et
devenir conseiller général m'a permis
effectivement de prendre encore plus
conscience de cette réalité magnifique
vous avez d'abord été membre de l'udf si
vous avez créé votre propre parti
politique donc d'abord appelé le forum
des républicains sociaux devenus ensuite
le parti chrétien démocrate
comment vous définiriez vous
vos convictions politiques et le
fondement idéologique de ce mouvement là
le fondement idéologique
mon engagement politique et le respect
de la personne humaine de la conception
à la mort naturelle
voilà je pourrais rajouter comme une
cerise sur le gâteau et pardon pour le
fond ce qui est fait c'est que pour moi
tout homme même le pire des hommes même
le pire de mes adversaires et aimé de
dieu autant que je le suis je dois dire
qu'avec l'expérience
autant j'avais l'intuition dans le coeur
qui avait été blessé par cette loi sur
l'avortement alors je mettais mes
enfants au monde
l'expérience de ses 40 ans m'ont montré
que si l'on touche aux plus petits
d'entre nous que nous avons tous été
celle d'hier l'embryon c'est l'humanité
tout entière qui est touché et qui est
fragilisé et quand on voit aujourd'hui
malheureusement le traitement qui est
réservé aux hommes à la personne humaine
et bien j'en ai fait qu être confortée
par rapport à cette analyse en qui vous
vous retrouver aujourd'hui au niveau de
l'engagement politique et de toutes ces
questions que vous évoquez la place de
l'homme dans la société
l'europe qui revient au devant de
l'actualité
quel est votre votre héritier vient pas
c'est pas ils sont pas nombreux sans
parole mais c'était ça fait partie aussi
du chalenge moi je crois beaucoup
je crois beaucoup en jean frédéric
poisson bien sûr qui a été battu de
façon scandaleuse
compte tenu de la qualité de la personne
mais bon c'est comme ça c'est la
démocratie et et c'est ainsi
jean-frédéric une responsabilité très
importante sur les épaules pour porter
justement cette primauté de la personne
humaine il ya une personnalité aussi à
laquelle je veux rendre hommage même si
nous avons des nuances et des nuances
importantes même sur le fond mais si
gérard marché gérard chaix une
expérience politique qui ne peut que
servir notre pays voilà il faudra
que ce soit affirmé de façon claire la
primauté de l'homme à saint quentin en
yvelines sans réelle surprise c'est le
maire d'elancourt jean michel fourgous
qui est devenu jeudi dernier le nouveau
président de l'agglomération successeur
de michel laugier démissionnaire après
son élection au sénat jean michel
fourgous devra avant tout aux oeuvres et
à l'unification de sa majorité
camille lambert et wilfrid richy la peur
ne me dirige et l'alpe et non la
collaboration doit être basé sur le
respect et la confiance
battu lors de la primaire de la droite
pour la présidence de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines joséphine
coleman berger maire de plaisir n'a pas
mâché ses mots avant que ne soit ouvert
le scrutin un discours qui laissait
planer le doute d'une candidature de
dernière minute mais qui finalement se
voulait surtout une mise en garde un
dialogue et apaisement devront être les
maîtres mots de cette nouvelle
gouvernance à jean michel fourgous et
lui quelques instants plus tard n'a pas
manqué de lui répondre en insistant sur
son état d'esprit qu'il dit fédérateur
j'ai voulu prendre la parole pour
réaffirmer mon engagement puisque vous
savez je m'occupe du projet territoire
et ce projet de territoire est justement
un socle fédérateur donc c'était pour
rappeler que c'était important que nous
allions dans ce sens élu par 38 voix sur
74 possible le nouveau président a été
opposée lors du vote au maire socialiste
de magny les hameaux battront lyon ce
dernier en a profité pour prôné le
rassemblement vous depuis plusieurs
semaines de coopération est réel et
partagée au delà d'une minorité ou
majorité parmi les vice présidences
quatre ont été réservées pour les
communes dites minoritaires commune qui
annonceront dans les prochains jours si
elle accepte ou non cette main tendue
quant aux priorités de son mandat jean
michel fourgous souhaite miser sur les
atouts du territoire
on est aujourd'hui quand même une des
plates formes entrepreneuriales un peu
modèle en france donc il s'agit de la
conforter aussi bien pour les jeunes
chefs d'entreprise que des entreprises
déjà installées que pour les grands
groupes qui sont présents
également développé est une plate forme
d'exemplarité aussi au niveau
universitaire il faut qu' on est un
modèle éducatif de l'enseignement
supérieur qui soit qui nous place dans
le fameux classement de shanghai dans le
top 20 est on en train d'organiser bien
sûr ces choses reste que pour le moment
l'heure est aussi à la mobilisation
entre menaces sur l'avenir de la ligne
18 et diminution des dotations
financières de l'état je vous en parlais
dans les titres le conseil municipal de
guyancourt a adopté la mesure le 30 juin
dernier un périmètre d'étude est mise en
place sur le centre ville c'est un
dispositif pour permettre de préserver
le quartier du village et de réguler les
constructions de logements les
précisions de nicolas landry le village
coeur historique de la commune de
guyancourt avec l'église saint victor la
ferme fortifiée de châteauneuf et des
maisons anciennes
un espace urbain dorénavant protégé par
un périmètre d'étude un outil prévu par
le code de l'urbanisme pour contrôler la
construction de logements maintenant à
chaque fois qu'une demande de permis de
construire sera déposé la ville a
à trois ans pour surseoir à cette
décision ce qui nous permet de prendre
le temps de bien protéger notre village
objectif permettre d'étudier des permis
de construire pour préserver le
patrimoine et de l'architecturé du
centre ville pourquoi là on est aussi
dans des maisons des bâtiments qu'on
veut protéger par exemple cette maison
là regardez qui est très hot février des
vieilles cartes postales de guyancourt
c'était un hôtel autrefois des cas
d'espèce différents en fonction de la
volonté municipale et de la zone
concernée par le périmètre d'étude avant
d'en être arrivé là aussi en nous disant
je vais détruire cette maison et
construire une centaine de logements
c'est le terrain derrière et est assez
grand mais bon quelque chose pareille
totalement inacceptable pour nous le
fait qu'on ait voté ce périmètre d'étude
permet d'empêcher cela on a eu des
longues discussions avec le promoteur
avec des allers-retours leur fait revoir
leur projet
plusieurs fois on arrivait à quelque
chose d'acceptable on a fait baisser le
nombre de logements neufs dont c'est la
sueur et de l'intégration dans
l'environnement que c'était des petits
immeubles qui ressemble plus à des
grandes maisons enfin il ya tous ces
allers-retours avec le promoteur je
souhaite qu'on arrive à un accord est
finalement le projet se fait maintenant
alors je crois que ils ont vendu à peu
près tout
cette prérogative municipal va s'étendre
sur une durée de 10 ans et guyancourt
toujours qui conservera bien son centre
de pmi la protection maternelle et
infantile
le site va bien déménager dans de
nouveaux locaux ceux de l'ancienne école
maternelle
eugénie cotton le conseil départemental
des yvelines en charge de la pmi a acté
l'acquisition du site pour un peu moins
de 800 milles euros
il ya deux ans élus et habitants
s'étaient mobilisés pour réclamer le
maintien du centre menacé de fermeture
et les pmi de la verrière et de magny
les hameaux ont par exemple arrêter leur
permanence ce début 2016
les températures ont baissé ces derniers
jours et vous avez d'ailleurs peut-être
déjà allumé votre cheminée chaque année
51 1 millions de stères sont consommés
en france selon le nfc le premier pays
consommateur de bois de chauffage en
europe et l'office national des forêts a
ouvert à un nouveau point de vente à
côté de rambouillet avec la société
molinario reportage de mélanie poquet et
de camille lambert mardi matin 9 heures
julien débute sa journée de livraison
direction la verrière chez patrick
bellot ce client a acheté trois stères
de bois de chauffage soit environ 3
mètres cubes de buch
pour diminuer les notes de de chauffage
moi me chauffe en tout électrique donc
ça permet de diminuer la facture edf
comme lui de nombreux français se
chauffent au bois 51 millions de stères
sont consommées chaque année une demande
toujours importante qui a poussé
l'office national des forêts et la
société molinario à ouvrir un nouveau
point de vente
il nous du ray le 16 octobre julien en
est le responsable
donc nous on est sur du bois sec qui
peut être brûlé brûlé immédiatement par
les clients d'écrire dès qu'il rentre ça
permet de d'avoir une meilleure
combustion du bois qui libère l'énergie
de chauffage ce qui permet aussi de
parents crasse et votre votre chemise le
carburant ou le ou plutôt la l'énergie
de demain et ça fait partie des énergies
renouvelables et donc il est important
aussi que l'onef montre cet exemple là
en disant que le bois est important dans
l'avenir pour consommer être consommés
en tant que bois énergie désormais le n9
molinario dispose de trois sites de
distribution de bois de chauffage ce
dernier situé à vieille-église en
yvelines pourra alimenter plus
facilement le secteur de rambouillet il
est possible de se faire livrer ou de
retirer sa commande directement sur
place
c'est une association de maurepas qui
agit pour développer les liens entre les
quartiers la jeunesse ce trait d'union
organisait une conférence débat la
semaine dernière après avoir créé une
exposition sur l'histoire de
l'immigration entre les deux rives c'est
le nom de cette conférence qui se tenait
à l'université versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
elle revenait sur la colonisation
française une histoire trop souvent
oubliés aux yeux du célèbre historien
benjamin stora qui animait le rendez
vous il a été interrogé par patrick
jacques de dixmude faire en sorte que
soient mieux connus davantage connue
l'histoire de l'immigration l'histoire
de la colonisation qui sont des sujets
d'étude qu'ils sont
pas suffisamment développée à mon sens
dans l'enseignement dans les programmes
scolaires dans les univers politique et
médiatique
donc c'est ça le message c'est faire
connaître davantage notre elle veut être
la meilleure boulangerie de france la
maison et de pâte à pain à jouer au
repos chartrain participer à une
émission concours sur la chaîne m6
bonsoir antonia et richard hill de verre
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes et les
propriétaires de cette boulangerie de
pâte à pain richard vous occupez vous
plus particulièrement de la partie à
boulangerie viennoiserie antonia vous
êtes vous en charge la pâtisserie alors
vous représenterez donc les yvelines
demain dans l'émission la meilleure
boulangerie de france votre passage est
programmée à partir de 18h35 on va en
parler dans un instant présentons
d'abord votre votre établissement la
boulangerie de pâte à pain c'est une
boulangerie qui a une particularité
c'est d'utiliser des produits de saison
et aussi des produits locaux ont essayé
aux particuliers
voilà de montrer qu'on est capables
d'utiliser des produits locaux de
voilà d'avoir cet échange de proximité
actuellement on a une pâtisserie avec
une pomme qui s'appelle la gloire de
pontchartrain d'accord donc pour la
ville de jaar pontchartrain allemand ça
fait ça fait plutôt pas mal donc ça
vient de petits bergers qui a juste à
côté donc voilà on essaye de promis à
promouvoir tout ça dans notre
boulangerie pâtisserie partenaires se
dire qu'on ne trouve pas forcément
toutes les pâtisseries à tout moment de
la saison c'est ça va dépendre aussi de
la période
c'est vrai oui l'a pas l'instinct par
exemple on a fini avec les fraises ne
trouve plus les fraisiers une forte
houle et non plus trois
donc là on essaye d'aider travail et de
la pêche l'épreuve les flics arrivent et
les mots rend donc avec l'automne donc
on essaye d'échangés ça parce qu'ils
aiguisent ouvrait la carte souvent et
qu'est ce que vous nous confectionnons
on a parlé de la gloire de pontchartrain
qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce qu'on peut
trouver en ce moment à de pâte à pain
voilà la gloire de pontchartrain avec
les pommes des saisons non s'il est apte
avec des figues celle-ci baron qui va
pas tarder à arriver les agrumes qui
vont bientôt arriver frais exotique on
va commencer à sortir voilà c'est un
tout qui vient au fur à mesure
plusieurs produits le pain d'ailleurs
leur avait apporté assez physique et des
78 on vous en remercier et pourquoi
essayer le web de de produire avec des
produits locaux justement pourquoi c'est
important pour vous de se fournir aux
alentours là on sort de maisons tous les
deux de maison à ses prestigieuses par
rapport à notre parcours
moi j'ai travaillé pendant quelques
années pour la maison de notre antonia
travaillé dans des restaurants et dans
des hôtels sur le brésil
l'arlésienne pendant pas mal d'années et
c'est une
c'est un état d'esprit qui existe dans
ces maisons là c'est ce qu'ils nous ont
transmis et voilà nous on allait moi
j'ai en ma famille j'ai les ans qu'il y
ait des personnes qui sont artisans qui
ont travaillé la terre qui ont travaillé
toutes ces choses là donc on veut
retransmettre et montrer aux gens que ça
existe toujours pas rendre votre
parcours vous un petit peu parlé déjà
mais pourquoi justement créer votre
établissement qu'est ce qui vous a
poussé à lancer votre affaire c'était il
ya un an vous l'avez vous l'avez ouvert
en 2016 cette boulangerie ce dont on a
ouvert fin juin 2016
ça s'est fait un petit peu sur le qui
vive ça a été très rapide l'ouverture on
a commencé à en discuter octobre à 2015
d'accord octobre 2015 on s'est dit tiens
on va faire un business ensemble on va
faire quelque chose parce que on
travaille tous les deux dans
l'alimentaire voir l'été heureux pour ça
et puis on a commencé on a commencé à
chercher un local à trouver un local
janvier fin janvier ont démarré les
travaux
on a tout refait à neuf et on ouvrait un
mois de juin donc ça a été vraiment très
très rapide c'était pas quelque chose de
vraiment prémédité
alors vous participez donc demain je les
dis à la meilleure boulangerie de france
cette émission de la chaîne m6 vous
serez opposé une boulangerie essonnienne
pour gagner votre place en finale
régionale ça c'est vendredi
suspense donc à suivre demain antonia
pourquoi vous lancer dans cette aventure
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à participer
à cette émission à vous inscrire en fait
c'était les chrétiens cno ans inscrits à
ce les clients qui visitent le cas oui
un jour on a ici un coup de fil de
l'impro deux anciens qui nous est dit
tiens feu et un tri ace qui vous
souhaitez participer
donc après cet appel on a un passé
encore pour notre
j'assume ce dossier pressez le jus
présélection sur dossier élections
et voilà on a cité pas typé pour paul et
de philips qui on aime bien les cours
dans les cerveaux concours puis ça
permet de nous booster un petit peu
aussi
et aussi de produire avec les caméras
derrière c'est pas difficile c'est pas
un petit peu oui enfin surprenant au
début c'est plus le côté surprenant
d'accord qui est pas facile pas facile à
gérer
on a démarré il y avait un caméraman au
script donc ça a été à l'ouverture de la
boutique après son arrivée à 15
donc ça commence à faire tout de suite
un peu plus impressionnant après il
reste il reste assez discret c'est des
gens qui sont dans la salle en messieurs
c'est du reste discret il arrive à
naviguer entre nous nous on allait quand
même toute la fabrication le journal
hier à faire donc il y avait pas mal à
faire mais voilà juste d'un petit temps
d'adaptation au début un petit coup de
stress forcément qu'on a eu et puis
après ça s'est fait tranquillement sans
souci une dernière question très
rapidement au delà du fait de savoir si
vous allez vous qualifier on découvrira
ça demain le
le suspense est et à attendre jusqu'à
demain qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
a apporté cette émission est ce que ça a
été une expérience enrichissante pour
vous on peut dire ça ouais c'est vrai
c'est vraiment enrichissant sur ce côté
humain on voit beaucoup sur les
émissions tous m'ont dit c'est une
aventure exceptionnelle ce ça mais on a
du mal à y croire à partir du moment où
il l'a pas vécu la cera qui est un beau
partage que ce soit avec les personnes
du jury qui s'assoit avec toutes les
personnes qui a derrière qu'on voit pas
toujours avec les autres concurrents
dont c'est fait les amitiés avec des
personnes voilà il ya toujours un bel
échange et c'est ses skis qu'on peut
retenir de nous de cette partie vous
souhaite bonne chance en tout cas merci
antonia et chari de verre d'avoir été
avec nous propriétaire de la maison de
pâte à pain qui participe donc demain à
l'émission la meilleure boulangerie et
de france le passage et à 18h35 et pour
en savoir davantage sur la boulangerie
rendez vous sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
côté loisirs et encore sport également
du bmx le club des clayes-sous-bois
organisé hier sa toute première
compétition sur sa nouvelle piste
un équipement ouvert officiellement
depuis début septembre plus de 400
concurrents ont tenté de dompter les
nouvelles boss nicolas d'andry est
nickel et l'hydro des coups de pédales
sur vitaminée de la bagarre dans les
virages bienvenue sur le pen de bmx et
les clayes-sous-bois ce dimanche 22
octobre plus de 400 biker se sont donné
rendez vous pour participer à cette
compétition amicale le niveau les
régional mais aussi national on a des
pilotes qui viennent d'autres
départements et même d'autres régions on
a
des pilotes
qui sont allés aux championnats du monde
qui ont fait les
des manches de coupe du monde et du coup
tout ça cette compétition également
permis aux bikers de tester la toute
nouvelle piste du club inauguré début
septembre plus d'un million d'euros ont
été investis pour créer un tracé de 350
mètres homologué par les instances
fédérales
après quelques tours de piste premier
verdict à l'école franchement aller à
ces techniques allaient roulante les
virages sont propres donc
on fait au max on prend comme on veut
technique et pas trop dangereuse les
virages sont bien compliqué à prendre
des sacs est marrant pour dompter les
bosses les 400 participants tous leurs
propres techniques par exemple sur dans
les virages sur les pas les parties plat
mais relancée et bien pousser sur disque
à enrouler tout ça mais bon soit ses
plus grosses il faut bien et techniques
faut pas taper faut être précis un
repérage de la piste qui pourrait faire
la différence lors de la prochaine
édition 2010 8 l'événement sera cette
fois-ci officielle et comptera pour le
classement général avant de refermer ce
journal l'automne c'est aussi la saison
des champignons dans les forêts du
département l'association des
naturalistes des yvelines organise des
balades pour rechercher à ces précieux
fruits des bois est direction l'étang du
moulin un renard à guyancourt avec
nicolas landry donc ça c'est le champion
le plus dangereux le calice de la mort
un champignon responsable de 90 % des
cas d'empoisonnement à ne pas confondre
avec les autres espèces de la famille
des amanites libériez tikrit cible oui
il ya des amanites comestibles tout à
fait il ya des mecs qui sont comestibles
qui sont bonnes mais pas il y en a
certains qui sont très dangereuses et
donc les amanites s'est mélangé il ya
des très dangereuse des très bonnes
cette promenade organisée par
l'association des naturalistes des
yvelines permet de découvrir plusieurs
types de champignons spécialiste en
mycologie jérôme à faire reconnaît
conseil et explique les caractéristiques
des découvertes très jolie verdad pas
courant de champion verwaerde comme ça
le clitocybe anisé alizés ça c'est comme
au sud
d'abord j'ai appris qu'il y avait
beaucoup plus de champignons non
comestibles que de champignons
comestibles
la preuve en est mon panier qui n'a qui
n'a je crois aucun champignons
comestibles ou si ce n'est des
champignons qui n'auront aucun intérêt
gustatif
moi je connais essentiellement les cèpes
et les volets dont je m'aventure
rarement sur autre chose
je connais les girolles mais paris si on
n'a pas les
et puis de moutons mais y'en a pas
beaucoup non plus alors j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses sur les champignons
ce qu'ils étaient comestibles et pas
comment les reconnaître également à ya
des champignons très bon qui sont
faciles à reconnaître
l'acteur beau les russules différents
champignons avec beaucoup plus d'espèces
toxiques comestibles plusieurs
explications à ce phénomène
il ya deux raisons il ya une raison
c'est qu'il ya une grande poussée de
sève a pas très longtemps et que la
poussée est finie et donc ne va plus
deuxième raison on est quand même dans
une zone très proche de ville et qu'il
ya beaucoup de ramasseurs de champignons
qui ne viennent que pour ramasser les
champignons comestibles et qui vident un
peu les forêts prochaine chasse aux
champignons ce samedi 28 octobre à lille
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal c'est à
retrouver en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]